ironhead is a man in his 60s known for
having an extremely strong iron-like
skull from a very young age ironhead his
brother iron crotch and sister roar have
been taught respective forms of martial
arts by their master ironhead can bang
his head into bricks without feeling a
thing iron crotch specializes in bearing
a crotch as strong as a diamond because
to train himself he has been hitting a
metal punching swing with his crotch
similarly rohr has a voice that can end
people's lives with a single screech she
has been accused of bursting people's
eardrums with her laugh and she breaks
at least five glasses with her voice to
train every day the three siblings were
praised for their talent when they were
young but as they got older so did their
talents people lost interest in them and
even though they continued training they
weren't respected for their efforts
moreover the iron siblings remained
mostly unemployed throughout their lives
which has now resulted in iron head
being neck deep in dead and as we all
know debt punches harder than a brick
one morning the debt collectors barge
into his apartment and gather all of his
belongings to make up for the money he
owes them their leader also sees
ironhead's old certificates and makes
fun of him for choosing a stupid path in
life after they leave he uses a tiny
chair and some leftover tableware to eat
whatever he has left ironhead pities
himself and finally comes to terms with
his [ __ ] life at the ripe age of 60
determined to make a change he sets off
looking for a job the first group he
comes across is a gangsters minions
distributing money among themselves the
amount of money they make for doing such
a simple job
shock siren had and he decides to join
the group in the following scene the old
man reaches a gym having followed the
group the right-hand man riker is about
to kick him out until the gang leader
jai stops him he is willing to hear
ironhead's problem but upon finding out
that he wants to join the gang he laughs
in the old man's face ironhead begs them
to give his head a chance but is
ultimately kicked out at night
ironhead's daughter and his grandson
come to his house offering help however
he is too proud of a man to accept money
from them hoping to keep him busy the
daughter leaves her son to stay with him
for a few days although ironhead doesn't
appreciate it he hands the kid a ball to
keep him entertained the next morning
jai's minions are driving down a street
nearby which reminds iron head of the
disrespect he was put through by the
creditors it pushes him to take things a
step further making him jump in front of
the car the gangsters quickly help him
and take him into the gang to ensure
they won't get in trouble on his men's
recommendation jai is ready to give iron
head a chance but first he has to prove
his worth by collecting money from a
very stubborn client iron head accepts
the challenge and goes looking for the
said man he turns out to be a successful
businessman having a lunch meeting with
his client at first ironhead simply asks
him to pay back the debt but as expected
the man ignores him for his second
attempt ironhead crosses a line and
spits his food at the businessman the
angry debtor bangs a glass bottle on
ironhead's head but instead of backing
down ironhead continues breaking several
bottles on himself the people around
look at the businessman as the villain
unlike how they would treat a usual debt
collector as a result the man feels
humiliated and hands ironhead his credit
card back in the gangster's base jai is
impressed by ironhead skills he gives
him a 30 commission from the money he
collected and promises to increase the
numbers if he continues the good work
jai's right-hand man riker burns in
jealousy because of the special
treatment the new guy gets he
desperately tries to change his boss's
mind claiming that iron had just got
lucky but the old man is still given a
chance in the following montage we see
him earning a fortune in a single month
he fills his house with expensive
furniture gadgets and alcohol he makes
sure to hide his profession from iron
crotch roar and the master knowing that
they won't support him what if iron
crotch gets mad and starts punching
himself in the
they even visit his house but iron head
lies about the furniture and manages to
keep his work a secret then one day he
is assigned to collect from a young
worker named bao his usual technique
works and bao gives him 30 000 yuan
which is all he had at the moment iron
hat allows it and brings the money to
the boss but riker calls it a scam their
policy tells them to never accept more
than half of the money and bow owes them
300 000 rupees riker insults ironhead
raising questions about his competence
and calling him a fraud in a fit of rage
iron had promises to collect the total
amount in three days if not he will have
to pay the entire amount himself and
will be treated as a debtor ironhead is
confident in his skills while riker
prays for his downfall at night when
returning home riker and his people beat
up the old man in the streets and tear
the paper that has bows accounts on it
this makes it harder for ironhead to
prove that bao owes them money he
somehow picks himself up and returns
home another man knocks at his door some
time later to return his share of money
ironhead is happy to accept it but just
then his daughter and her policeman
husband arrive home they believe the guy
is a debt collector and order him to get
out of the house ironhead doesn't want
them to know about his profession and
loses money in the process in the
following scene we see ironhead's
son-in-law at a house that has been
robbed the house belongs to bow and it
turns out that he is the one who stole
the money that was meant to be for his
mother's hospital bills he admits his
mistake and tells everyone it was to pay
off his debts the family shares an
emotional conversation after which bow
promises to never do something like that
again ironhead's son-in-law and his
colleagues also give the family a few
thousand yuan to help them the next day
iron head again goes to bow and uses his
old trick to get him to pay the
commotion takes place in the middle of
the street urging people to yell at bao
to pay up with no way out the poor man
hits himself on the head with a brick
mimicking iron head the old man simply
hands him a handkerchief and walks away
in regret he never wanted to use his
skill for bad and has a realization that
he is turning into a person he hates at
the same time jai and riker are watching
ironhead from their car jai always had
his doubts regarding him and riker works
hard to add fuel to the fire they know
for sure that he is going to fail but
plan to wait until three days are over
to take action against him later that
day iron crotch roar and the master
barge into ironhead's home and find out
how he got rich they are disgusted that
he would use his training to do
something so foul moreover the company
he works for takes advantage of the poor
and offers them loans at a disturbingly
high interest iron head is embarrassed
to the point he wants the ground to
swallow him he hands over the remainder
of his money to the master promising to
never return to work again but upon
seeing the amount of money the master
and his entire lot changed their minds
he declares them a team of four debt
collectors and joins ironhead at work
because nothing beats an iron bank
account the master beats up iron crotch
with a hammer in front of their clients
making them pay up in a hurry using the
same trick they earn thousands in only
an hour but they are yet to convince bow
he insists that he has no money but the
group wants him to sell the house to pay
them even though he and his family will
be homeless after that when vows still
doesn't pay rohr starts repeating the
words pay up outside his home she does
so for the next two days without
stopping and eventually bow's mother
allows him to sell the house in the next
scene ironhead and the team go to zhai
with the money xi insults riker for ever
doubting ironhead and makes him the
right-hand man ironhead is given power
over everyone in the gang much to
riker's annoyance for the next month
ironhead and the group continue
collecting money using the same
technique it works like a charm as
people are terrified of being hit with a
hammer as the master does to iron crotch
the group also makes a lot of money and
starts enjoying their lives to the
fullest moreover they take the
responsibility to train other gangsters
and make even more money from that then
on ironhead's birthday he throws a huge
party everyone enjoys themselves until
jai informs them of the big boss yawn's
arrival he invites ironhead zhai and the
rest to his car and congratulates him on
his birthday the man also takes the
chance to inform them that their company
is now providing loans to college
students they are young and
impressionable which yawn plans to take
advantage of ironhead doesn't feel
comfortable with the idea but he doesn't
dare to oppose the big boss the next day
they are asked to collect from a young
college girl she sees someone beat iron
crotch and is shaken to refrain from
suffering the same fate she agrees to
pay them by selling her naked pictures
this just got a lot darker they will
call her iron only fans iron head
watches her walk away with the gangsters
and feels guilty to have had a hand in
this trying to forget about the girl he
decides to spend time with his grandson
instead they go on a cruise trip
together and enjoy the next week in the
meantime the college girl is manipulated
into going into a room with riker
another less important member of the
gang is ling who doesn't like the girl
being exploited he tries to retaliate
but is shut down by his bosses after the
trip iron head his grandson and the rest
of the group are walking down a beach
when they come across bow's mother and
daughter living out in the open the
little girl accuses ironhead of making
her family suffer his grandson and her
get into a fight resulting in the boy
swinging a glass bottle at her ironhead
takes the hit and his head bleeds for
the first time due to the impact this is
the last straw and he no longer wants to
associate with yon zhai or their
business the next time he meets with yon
he makes his decision clear to him the
gangster is evidently not happy about
his best man quitting but surprisingly
enough he walks away without saying
anything after that ironhead meets ling
who was asked to take care of his
grandson the poor guy was beaten up by
yon's man who kidnapped the kid an
enraged iron head is ready to risk
everything for his grandson but before
that he calls his daughter and asks her
to remain safe elsewhere we see bow's
mother receive a credit card and an
apology letter from ironhead she can
finally buy a house and stay off the
streets in the next scene ironhead's
group barges into yon's gym with guns
the kid is let free and the gangsters
surrender because of the weapons but
then roar accidentally pulls the trigger
revealing that the guns are children's
toys the group is then captured and
asked to take a video of college girls
john wants to strip them of their
principles to prove they are as foul as
the rest of the employees ironhead
refuses to hold the camera and instead
holds a gun to his head seconds before
he is shot the swat team drops from the
ceiling having debunked the money
laundering the gang has been involved in
finally all the gangsters including ian
and jai are arrested and the girls are
also let free in the last scene ironhead
moves out of his home and goes to live
with his daughter's family he iron
crotch roar and their master vow to
never use their skills hastily again
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching